nesting filthy oxes gollum a miserable
wretched creature from the works of
j.r.r tolkien who's easy to hate and
just as easy to pity after being a side
character in both bilbo and frodo's
journeys and all of the adaptations of
them he's now the main character in his
own game the lord of the rings gollum
now as gamespot's certified lord of the
rings expert i recently attended a
hands-off preview event for the game i
saw a big chunk of gameplay and had the
opportunity to ask the development team
some questions so here are seven things
i learned the lord of the rings golem
takes place roughly parallel to the
events of the early chapters of the
fellowship of the ring as a little recap
in the hobbit gollum loses the one ring
or should i say the one ring loses
gollum only for it to be picked up by
bilbo baggins and his hands is in the
time between the hobbit and the lord of
the rings gollum is desperate to find
the ring once again and so he eventually
leaves the cave which he's called home
for a couple of hundred years to try and
track down bilbo through merkwood but
the trail has gone cold he eventually
turned to go to mordor where he was
captured by sauron's forces and tortured
into giving up the name of the one
ring's new carrier and where they could
be found
after leaving mordor aragorn captured
gollum and gandalf interrogated him to
find out what sauron knows now there's a
lot to play around with here in terms of
story but it won't cross over with the
fellowship's quest too much allegedly
ending somewhere around the mines of
moria the dev team also confirmed that
there wouldn't be flashbacks to before
he found the ring this is very much
gollum's game so who knows if we'll even
actually meet up with frodo and the rest
of the fellowship let's go over gollum's
abilities then true to tolkien's
description he is a sneaky stealthy but
very athletic boy who prefers to avoid
head-on confrontation but can still do
some damage when cornered as a stealth
action game prepare to do a lot of
sneaking as well as a lot of climbing
the levels of the game that i saw in
action kirith ongol and merkwood were
both filled to the brim with climbing
and platforming puzzles gollum can leap
over large gaps as well as climb various
formations in the environment like vines
and rock faces but when he's hanging on
by just his arms he has a stamina bar
that begins to deplete when it comes to
stealth just like practically every
modern game with stealth elements
there's a kind of detective mode that
you can activate it's called golem
vision which
i don't remember that from the book but
in the gameplay that i saw in kirith
ungol golem was hiding from two orcs and
activated the golem vision and it showed
not only where the orcs were in the
environment but it also showed hiding
spots and sort of the general direction
of your objective combat then you can
knock out enemies but it's incredibly
risky first of all unlike most modern
stealth games enemies make noise when
attacked and taking them down takes a
while so you really need to be sure that
the coast is clear you also need to make
sure you even have enough stamina to
finish the job so honestly sneaking
might just be your best bet gollum
obviously doesn't have a huge weapon
wheel full of things to use but he can
pick up small items like rocks to throw
and cause a distraction that way
there will also be boss-like encounters
but apparently they will be more puzzly
than combat driven we've talked a lot
about gollum but we haven't even
mentioned smeagle the other main
character in this game so to speak
before being corrupted by the one ring
gollum was a hobbit-like creature called
smeagle his hundreds of years with the
ring changed him into the figure we know
of him today but over that time his
personality cracked for lack of a better
word the golem personality is full of
hatred hatred for the elves himself and
despite craving its return even the ring
smeagle on the other hand is the more
optimistic naive side who remembers what
it was like to feel emotions like
happiness and love as a result they
argue and in the game this is presented
as a choice-driven mechanic either side
with gollum or with smeagol siding with
one strengthens that persona affecting
other things in the game such as the
fate of some characters as well as
certain situations you stumble across
but it doesn't give either side unique
abilities the dev team said that this
wouldn't make sense law wise because
it's two personalities yes but they are
within the same body the choice i saw in
action was gollum arguing with smeagol
over whether or not to kill and eat a
bug now obviously that's not a huge
decision in the grand scheme of things
but it did offer a really nice character
moment when the smeagol side won it
showed how pitiful and lonely he is and
honestly it had it had huge it was pity
that stayed bilbo's hand energy we
obviously know that gollum is going to
be in the game but which other
recognizable faces from tolkien's vast
middle earth can we expect a good few as
it turns out in kirath ongol there are
numerous references to shelob from
webbing everywhere to gollum mentioning
her name outright i also saw a cutscene
featuring a fel beast the big winged
creatures that the nazgul ride so i
wouldn't be surprised if they show up
too throughout the gameplay i saw gollum
was having audio
flashes i'm unsure if they were
flashbacks or flash forwards to his
interrogation with gandalf later on in
the gameplay that i saw we ended up in
merckwood and gandalf and thranduil were
there discussing the one ring and gollum
now given that aragorn is the person who
brings gollum to merkwood i wouldn't be
surprised if he showed up too the
development team has also introduced new
characters there was an elf called mel
who was in the gameplay that i saw
although i didn't get to see mel i just
heard her voice she has also been
imprisoned in thranduil's halls and
gollum strikes an uncanny friendship
with them to the point where he's even
trying to rescue her from the prison
that she's in if you're on the hunt for
more easter eggs and references to the
lord of the rings apparently they will
be bountiful and there will be
collectibles that will definitely appeal
to tolkien fans in terms of locations
i've mentioned a few already we'll
definitely be exploring kirith ongol and
merkwood the devs also name-dropped
barador during the presentation which
makes a lot of sense given that that's
where gollum is taken when he's captured
by sauron you can also explore gollum's
cave where he has a bunch of drawings
that he's done on the rocks and on the
walls
of events in his life if you choose to
interact with them you get these kind of
nice character moments where both gollum
and smeagol will weigh in on their
interpretation of the events a big
question when it comes to tie in media
is the lord of the rings gollum cannon i
can confirm it is the development team
daedalic struck a deal with middle-earth
enterprises who ultimately have to
approve everything to make sure it's
accurate to what j.r.r tolkien wrote
while we know a little about gollum's
journey at this point in the story there
is still plenty that's been left
unwritten and so the development team
have gone in and wrote their own story
in terms of the aesthetic gollum
obviously doesn't look like the one from
peter jackson's film trilogy nor is he
played by andy serkis in the lord of the
rings golem he is played by wayne
forrester a british voice actor who has
been in a bunch of things but most
recently he was one of the male
protagonist voices in elden ring i'm not
sure who is doing the voice of gandalf
but whoever it is they are seriously
doing their best ian mckellen we
actually don't have that long to wait
until the lord of the rings golem
launches it'll be hitting playstation 4
playstation 5 xbox one xbox series x and
s and pc on september 1st a whole day
before the new lord of the rings tv
series the rings of power premieres on
amazon prime the game is confirmed to be
coming to nintendo switch later this
year but there's no release date just
yet there won't be a collector's edition
but there will be some kind of digital
deluxe edition with some more bells and
whistles if that's your thing and as
someone with the extended editions of
all the movies yes including the hobbit
trilogy that's that's probably me
anyway that's everything i learned about
the lord of the rings gollum from that
recent preview event that i went to if
you have any more questions about it
make sure to drop them in the comments
below i will be going through them and
answering as best as i can or you can
come find me on twitter i'm at lucy
james games for more on the lord of the
rings gollum as well as any upcoming
lord of the rings stuff
keep your eyes peeled to gamespot and
gamespot universe